so
this is greendale
a friendly neighborly town
maybe sort of an old-fashioned town
oh we've grown through the years here in
greendale but still we've kept in touch
with old friends
i suppose i know our people pretty well
you're bound to in my profession
and there are ever so many interesting
human stories to tell about them
but i wonder if you wouldn't like to
hear the story that i think is the most
important one i could tell
it begins just across the street from me
over in the offices of greendale's
leading law firm
now we're not particularly interested in
bates and bates except that the girl i
want to tell you about has been
pleasantly employed there ever since she
graduated from high school
wendy jameson i mean wendy hill i'm
always forgetting to use her married
name
you see she'd just been married at the
time our story begins
well wendy hill was about as fine and
wholesome a girl as you'd find anywhere
and everything had been working out
right for wendy lately
of course she had no way of knowing that
this would be the day that would change
the whole course of her life
when i heard the scream i moved fast
you can imagine how i felt when i saw
that the victim was windy
our town knows how to handle emergencies
wendy hadn't regained consciousness yet
and of course i went over to the
hospital with her
it took only about half an hour to patch
wendy's bruises and send her upstairs to
a quiet room
her husband jim had come over
when he wasn't seriously hurt thank
goodness but she was still suffering
from considerable shock
i just dropped in on her for a minute in
a room
well here you are hello jim hello doctor
hello wendy
well young lady look what you've got
yourself into this time i hope you're
not going to keep me here very long
i couldn't stand that
oh
oh it hurt
is she all right doctor woods of course
she is don't worry about her
and don't you worry the little lady
just take it easy and we'll have you out
of here no time at all
but next morning i was almost forced to
swallow those cheerful words
i just finished dictating to listen
alone when the phone rang it was the
hospital
nurse henderson wanted to give me the
results of routine tests on monday
what she said was surprising and not so
good
one day's your analysis showed sugar
of course i asked for confirmation
nurse henderson said she'd make a blood
sugar test immediately
sugar
that points straight at diabetes
it might be a false alarm but still i
thought i'd get in touch with jim
blow him would you see if you've got mr
hill on the phone right away yes sir
thanks
i haven't hit the hill dr wood thanks
hello jim
say jim
i wonder if you could knock off for just
half an hour so and come over to my
office
no nothing to get upset about
no i'd i'd rather talk to you here
fine jim
no don't rush just come as soon as you
can
oh and jim
do you think you could stop by home and
bring your service discharge papers with
you
fine thanks
goodbye
while jim is on his way to my office
nurse henderson over at the hospital was
starting wendy's blood sugar tests
hello jim hello dr wood glad to see you
sit down has uh something going wrong
with wendy
well
just a second jim i'll be right with you
hello
yes
yes miss anderson
275
yes i guess that's it
much obliged
now jim
i don't want you to be alarmed this has
nothing to do with wendy's injuries
thank goodness
but a routine urinalysis showed sugar in
the urine
and that's a telltale sign of diabetes
diabetes
wendy
is impossible
couldn't have gotten it wrong that's why
i had a blood sugar test made for
confirmation
that was the hospital on the phone just
now
are you going to tell wendy
of course
she has to know she has to cooperate
with us
you know i just can't believe this about
wendy
she seems so well good appetite plenty
of pepperoni well then you can thank
your lucky stars she was knocked down by
that truck yesterday i don't get it well
if it hadn't been for that accident i
don't think she'd have had your analysis
for months
you look okay jim
oh sure
did you uh bring your service discharge
papers with you well yes here they are
right
that's good
as a matter of fact i just took out some
new insurance last week pass exam just
fine and that's even better
we'll drop in on wendy right now
hello sweetheart
hello darling
jim
something's wrong
i can tell by the look on your face
what is it doctor well we made routine
tests of your urine and blood here in
the hospital
and both tests
show sugar
sugar
what
that means
yes diabetes
oh [ __ ]
now they're dear
oh what am i going to do
i wish we'd never been married wait a
minute wendy
i thought you were a sensible girl dr
wood you don't understand
we wanted children i know what diabetes
means i know a girl has it
they told her this
well they said you could never have a
baby
listen to me wendy
you and jim certainly can have children
the chance of diabetes affecting your
children is small
we won't worry about it now
but i'm still full frame look here
it's a fact that heredity is important
in diabetes
children in diabetic families have a far
greater chance of winding up with a
disease than those in families without
it
but the chance is well worth running
unless both parents have the disease
now as for you
we know about it soon enough to bring
you under good control
you can live in comfort and security and
you certainly can have children
if you cooperate in your treatment
i'll try oh
oh my i'm hurt of course it does
but you know wendy that accident was
probably the luckiest thing that ever
happened to you
strange how surprised i'd been to find
diabetes in wendy
hardly any symptoms that might have worn
me
and yet that's often the case as 20
years practice here in greendale has
certainly taught me
jake wilson for example
i never knew jake was deliberately
concealing his symptoms
he let things go so long that dr van
voorhees and i had to take part of
jake's right leg three years ago
and tommy higgins
just couldn't seem to get a hit anymore
because breaking his heart
diabetes often affects eyesight
tommy's under good control now
now emma thorndike
anybody could have seen she was a setup
for diabetes
it strikes much often among fat people
and my really hated giving up those
chocolates but it saved her life
it's amazing how suddenly diabetes seems
to begin in children
on thursday her mother told me little
janie barrett began complaining about
being tired
she started asking for water every few
minutes a danger signal
luckily mrs barrett brought her to me
right away
janie's on insulin now and doing well
shortly after sending wendy home i
stopped in to see her
it was on a saturday
hello jim oh hello doctor hello wendy
hello dr west well jim how's our patient
today
she looks okay to me doctor
but man oh man is she ever a hard one to
get along
don't you believe it doctor this person
just won't follow orders in regard to
housework
i'll get even with you oh excuse me
doctor i've got wendy's lunch on the
stove go right ahead jim
well put your coat over there doctor
thanks wendy
now young lady tell me just how do you
feel
well still a little sore and stiff but
otherwise i'm fine
and jim has been so considerate it's
ready
but don't come and get it i'll bring it
in
oh
you've saved my life i'm starving
well you've got the right idea jim but
you might let her have just a little bit
more
okay doctor
well i should say so
i guess i just love eating
what's wrong with that anyhow it wasn't
making me fat
no but it was making your diabetes worse
you see a normal person has plenty of
insulin to handle a lot of sugars and
starches
but your trouble is that you don't have
enough insulin so it stands to reason
you have to go light on the starchy
stuff
that's right jim
insulin is necessary for the proper use
of starches and sugars
now with diabetic people careful diet
and other precautions are a great help
but when they're not enough we can thank
goodness call on outside though
and here it is in this little bottle
insulin
one of the greatest discoveries in
medical history
we're starting you off on insulin wendy
i don't know whether you'll stay on it
or not
most people do
your life and happiness are secure as
long as we have insulin to give you
you look pretty good
well you'd better be getting to your
lunch
and i'd better be getting to my other
patients
wendy was getting along even better than
i'd expected
she'd gone back to work just a week ago
thank you
see ya
you weren't here the last time i came in
no i was home for a few days oh that's
right
my wife was telling me uh
you had uh diabetes wasn't it
well i still haven't i guess well i'm
glad i came in
uh you didn't know my younger sister
carrie did you no i don't believe i did
and a couple of years ago they told her
she had diabetes
but she didn't pay any attention to what
those doctors told her oh she didn't no
and she got along all right
she just took witherspoon's golden
remedy every morning a night right up to
the day she died
wendy seemed to be getting a lot of free
advice
at first it didn't bother her
why wendy
why mrs barton how are you
you never did come to see our little
place yes i know
but i heard about your trouble my dear
and i didn't want to be getting in the
way at a time like this
diabetes is such a terrible thing oh i'm
getting along just fine mrs barton
yes i know but
you never can tell now mrs cameron she
just kept right on going downhill
i don't know how many people i've known
that just but dr wood says there's
nothing to worry about
well i hope he's right but
well
goodbye my dear goodbye
poor wendy was becoming the target for
too much uninformed talk
especially her great aunt henry etters
that old lady was inspecting wendy's new
home for the first time
you're going to have a baby
well i
hope so
sit down wendy i want to talk to you
you can't have a baby with diabetes oh
but i don't you know you can't have a
baby
worried unhappy and confused
wendy and her husband jim came to my
office the next afternoon
i guess i laid down the law to them
pretty hard
nothing gets me madder than loose
medical talk by people who don't know
what they're talking about
it's dangerous
i think i cleared things up pretty well
with wendy and jim
and they are a sensible pair
well the rest of the story goes pretty
fast and happily
tim was nervous there in the waiting
room but it was my pleasure to announce
to him that he was the father of a fine
new baby boy
my were they proud on the day they
brought the infant jimmy home for the
first time
as jimmy grew older wendy and jim would
have faced anything together for that
little child
jimmy's second birthday rolled around
there have been a couple of others since
big jim was always bringing something
home for that youngster seems to me
i made one call on the family back there
in the chickenpox season when jimmy was
three
now that he's a big grown-up four he and
wendy just dropped by occasionally for a
checkup
what a sturdy young fellow that jimmy is
a nice kid too
well that's about all there is to the
story i wanted to tell you
the story of wendy hill
oh yes wendy's going to have another
baby
her husband jim doesn't know it yet
you'll know before very long though he's
meeting wendy and jimmy downstairs
yes i guess the worst thing about
trouble is running away from it
letting fear keep you from doing what
you should do
wendy hill knows that today
there's no earthly reason now that we
have insulin why people with diabetes if
they act soon enough
can't live long and happy lives
lives where they can sometimes do some
good for other people too
i guess it's just about time for me to
have my own insulin
you